[Musik]
glaubt ihr den bewertungen bei amazon
alle ermessen helfers regen als erstes
gelistet zu werden und der beste weg
ganz nach bremen zu kommen
sie hat fünf sterne bewertungen doch wie
bekommt man fünf sterne wenn das produkt
einfach nur trash die stelle dieses
produkt bayern müssen schreibt eine fünf
sterne bewertung und schicken wir machen
selbst den test arbeiten verdeckt
alsfeld bewährter und bekommen all diese
produkte fast geschenkt für eine fünf
sterne bewertung so richtig premium sind
diese top bewerteten produkte leider
nicht das geht wirklich von kleinen
abweichungen bis hin zu lebensgefahr
[Musik]
er müssen rechnet im dezember mit
umsätzen von bis zu 120 milliarden
dollar
es wäre ein rekord der online handel
boomt in corona zeiten
dabei helfen auch die millionen von
bewertungen auf der plattform den kunden
vertrauen kunden diese lichterkette hat
fast immer die bestnote 5 sterne
die käufer sind happy super lichterkette
wir sind begeistert
hochwertige verarbeitung erzeugt eine
warme atmosphäre stabil und schickt
hängt bei uns im garten einfach top wir
hängen die kette bei uns in den garten
und fragen uns hat dieses produkt diese
exzellenten amazon bewertungen wirklich
verdient wir lassen die lichterkette im
labor von spezialisten untersuchen wie
hier im regenwasser testen das
testergebnis bei dieser leuchte ist
eindeutig negativ weil wir bei der
trasse prüfung haben wir wasser in den
fassungen feststellen können und das
darf so nach normativen vorgaben nicht
sein es kann im schlimmsten fall zu
einem tödlichen schlag auf die experten
vom verband der elektrotechnik raten
dringend davon ab sich bei
elektronischen amazon produkten auf die
bewertungen zu verlassen
die bewertung bei amazon sagt leider
überhaupt nichts über die sicherheit der
produkte aus und man kann bei amazon
sehr viel filtern
man kann zum beispiel den preis filtern
den hersteller filtern aber man kann
eben das thema sicherheit nicht fiebert
auch wenn man der lichterkette
sicherheitsmängel auf den ersten blick
nicht ansieht fragen wir uns doch wie
kann es sein dass so viele nutzer diese
lichterkette weiterempfehlen
der grund viele der amazon bewertungen
sind fake in reno im us bundesstaat
nevada treffen wir tommy noonan einen
experten für gefälschte amazon
er sagt ein großer teil von ihnen ist
nicht echt sondern gekauft
alle messen händler versuchen als erstes
team oder besser weg ganz nach oben zu
kommen sind fünf sterne bewertungen und
so versuchen sie an so viele fünf sterne
bewertungen wie möglich zu kommen egal
wertingen sind also käuflich für amazon
ein glaubwürdigkeitsproblem das problem
ist ja folgendes du kaufst ein produkt
wo du denkst das ist gut
und da kommt das produkt an und du
denkst was ist denn das für ein schrott
das kann auch nicht im interesse von
amazon sein und ist auch nicht im
interesse von amazon
die amazon zentrale in seattle der
konzern investiert millionen in den
kampf gegen fake bewertungen algorithmen
sollen diese aufspüren das unternehmen
schreibt uns amazon akzeptiert
ausnahmslos nur authentische bewertungen
wir entfernen gefälschte rezensionen und
gehen gegen alle an den missbrauch
beteiligten vor
sie finden die betrüger und wisse aber
dass schaden ist längst millionen kunden
haben aufgrund dieser bewertungen
sollten die kraft doch wie funktioniert
der kauf von bewertungen genau eine
einfache facebook suche bringt uns auf
die spur
es läuft über facebook gruppen hier
aufgelistet unzählige produkte für die
bewertungen geschrieben werden sollen
dort entdecken wir auch unsere
lichterkette die ware gibt es für eine
fünf sterne bewertung angeblich um so
lesen wir nehmen kontakt auf
ich hätte gerne diese lichterkette was
muss ich machen bestellt dieses produkt
beim essen schreibt eine fünf sterne
bewertung und schick mir einen
screenshot die kette kommt an
wir schreiben eine produkt rezension und
vergeben wie verlangt überall fünf
sterne anschließend schicken wir dem
agenten ein motto unserer fünf sterne
bewertung im gegenzug bekommen wir den
kaufpreis zurück überweisen
unser selbstversuch zeigt wie es
funktioniert er müssen händler kaufen
die bewertungen bei vermittlern diese
vermittler kontaktieren privatpersonen
die die fake bewertungen für sie
schreiben es sind abertausende verstreut
auf der ganzen welt
der schaden ist gigantisch wie ein
datenleck auf dem server eines
vermittlers beweist er allein hatte
viele tausend fünf sterne bewertungen
organisiert ich halte das problem für
riesengroß weil verbraucher werden hier
ganz bewusst getäuscht um eine gewisse
entscheidung zu treffen zu fällen und
dann noch eventuell irgendwann geld zu
überweisen und der volksmund nennt das
betrug wir setzen unseren selbstversuch
ford können wir einen ganzen raum mit
produkten einrichten die wir für fake
bewertungen erhalten
es funktioniert bestens insgesamt 56
produkte im wert von rund 2000 euro
nahezu gratis
für diese drohne sollen wir zusätzlich
zu fünf sterne bewertung noch ein
werbevideo drehen und bei amazon
hochladen auftrag zeigt euch begeistert
das urteil unserer drohnen pilotin fällt
anders aus das so schwer zu
kontrollieren
ich würde höchstens
wir lassen mehrere elektronikartikel aus
unserem gut gefüllten versuchsraum von
den spezialisten des vde überprüfen alle
wurden bei amazon bestens bewertet dank
gekauft der sterne top produkte sind es
leider nicht als wir haben tatsächlich
sechs produkte von ihnen bekommen und
haben bei allen mängeln gefunden die
mängel sind mal kleiner mal größer aber
es geht wirklich von kleinen
abweichungen bis hin zu lebensgefahr
wir zeigen unsere testergebnisse amazon
und bitten um stellungnahme antwort
die sicherheit unserer kunden hat
oberste priorität die hälfte der
fraglichen produkte war bereits vom
store entfernt worden bevor sie uns
darauf aufmerksam gemacht haben der rest
ist ebenfalls entfernt worden
aufgrund unserer recherchen beendete
müssen den verkauf der lichterkette über
skype fragen wir einen ehemaligen
amazon-manager unternimmt der konzern
genug gegen fake bewertungen
ich denke eher müssen muss mehr machen
sie müssen mehr personal mehr geld und
mehr technik investieren
sie müssen verkäufer die die regeln
brechen zurückverfolgen und zwar
häufiger überall auf der welt unseren
selbstversuch beenden wir auf den
wertstoffhof alle elektronischen
produkte die wir gratis bekommen haben
entsorgen wir aufgrund von
sicherheitsbedenken auch unsere fake
bewertungen löschen wir
amazon hatte sie nutzen teil entdeckt
das miese geschäft geht weiter fünf
sterne für schrott
seit wir schon mal auf fake bewertungen
reingefallen schreibt es uns in die
kommentare